uh this is from the daily mail pfizer
ceo says a
third covid vaccine dose will be needed
as soon as six months after someone
receives
two shots and then people will be
vaccinated
annually the reason i bring this up is
first they said you know it's two shots
they say it's three first had one mask
then two fine whatever
my point is not necessarily the amount
of shots you have to get i guess once a
year
the issue is the vaccine passports and
the private requirements
for you to carry around some form of
digital identity that will allow you
access
and carry around your private records if
they're coming out now saying well you
need three
what happens if you get your vaccine and
you're like great back to normal
now you have your vaccine passport we've
normalized this then the ceo of a
massive private corporation comes out
and says actually
you need three well now all the other
private corporations the walmarts the
stores the the cruises the airlines are
going to be like
well the ceo pfizer said it so we have
to update our rules because they're the
experts
now you are forced to go back in this is
why we can't allow this kind of thing to
be normalized
but it brings to the i bring this up
because the larger point you're making
about a digital identity
owned by the government is
for one you're completely correct we
can't allow
the ownership of our identities but i
think it's going to be private
corporations that do this yeah
there's going to be a consortium of
sorts that says we should have a
standard like a blockchain
thing and then you have your private key
won't everyone like this yeah but then
it's centralized because it's on the
blockchain
right now most blockchain projects are
not decentralized i'm here to tell you
folks
they're not really decentralized not in
the sense in which the dns system and
email
and the blogosphere and usenet if you
remember that and many other things the
backbone of the internet
is decentralized blockchain ain't
decentralized in that way this is why i
think um bitcoin is actually a really
great risk to freedoms and i've said
this for a long time
uh it'll be with a lot of money because
i think there's powerful interests that
realize the power of bitcoin and being
able to track
everything you do it's beautiful the the
artificial intelligence
the fact that the blockchain is public
they can track you
if you are using bitcoin you have
started publishing your digital identity
to a certain degree
again bitcoin's very valuable i have i
have some it's been skyrocketing in
value i think for obvious reasons
it's useful for governments but i
remember going back and way back in the
day
when bitcoin was first gaining some
prominence and i had some anarchist left
friends some anarchist right friends
and it was really the the anarchists
left weren't really paying attention to
this stuff
the the libertarian and ancap people i
knew were like this is amazing we can
have a system of value to exchange the
government can't track it
and i was like dude this is the most
easily tracked thing
ever what are you talking about and
they're like no you're wrong
and i was like wow how is it that you
have
walked into one of the most easily
surveilled systems
and you don't realize it so what happens
when bitcoin becomes a standard
it's skyrocketing in value what happens
when a bitcoin which has eight
decimal points becomes worth the
equivalent of one million dollars
you now have a digital international
standard of
easily tracked currencies that people
will say it's decentralized to a certain
degree
but if every massive major multinational
corporation requires the use of bitcoin
well it's not really decentralized then
because this international consortium
can simply say
we all agree we will not accept bitcoin
from ian this address
banned and then any address associated
with it banned
right and because it's publicly
exchanged
you will have to there's ways to do it
but you'll have to then
essentially launder your coins to
another address
and then to a different address maybe
using monero or something
so that they can't publicly see your
coins or associated with a certain
address but what happens if they say
if we track any of these coins
going through any address they're no
good anymore
well then there's nothing you can do
those coins are essentially defunct
and they've excised you from society
it's hard to do with cash
with hard us dollars you got paper money
it's valuable you can hand it off to
somebody they don't know who had it or
when they had it i mean they can track
it to a certain degree
with bitcoin ian's money could could be
deemed
all of the money and this address is now
worthless and anybody who trades in it
will be banned from the network as well
and people back i'm not trading with you
ian
there's no way to get that money out
that's a beaut
beautiful system i'm i'm i've never uh
look i understand the technology i think
ethereum's brilliant brilliant
technology it's gonna
do a lot of really great things but
people don't realize
you know when uh the far right as they
as they say
started taking bitcoin news outlets
started publishing the amount of money
these people had
there you go yeah i don't think using
bitcoin as a store of value is really
the future i think it's the smart
contracts themselves and the ability to
transact a token
a digital piece of information that
activates a program what's ethereum
yeah ethereum right right that's
brilliant technology you can remove the
middleman of the dude sitting there
flipping the switch for you once he gets
his paycheck like
that there's nothing to do that eos is
another one that's that's what uh
that's what uh the everpedia the
blockchain encyclopedia basically they
forked wikipedia
they added another million articles a
lot of them are auto-generated but
they've written a lot
by hand for sure um about
all kinds of topics that aren't in
wikipedia they're like
not notable enough or something or
people who are only internet famous or
or whatever and uh
and it's cool and i i support them they
actually are
um built on eos
um unfortunately they're an example
and i don't want to say anything too
negative about even eos here
but it bothers me i'm i'm sorry i just
have to say it
that that the block producers at least
back in 2019 i don't know what the
current situation is
the people who are responsible for
deciding what goes on
the eos blockchain they were all owned
by chinese
corporations so i mean okay
it's decentralized in one sense but it's
kind of centralized in another
really important sense too the issue is
private corporations of which there is
an ever decreasing amount that own
everything
the the ceo of disney can go to the ceo
of unilever and be like hey so we agree
like ian crossland's banned from society
right
and they'll make sure every company is
is off limits to you i truly believe we
need a program that will allow
every individual to spin up their own
token that they can use as their own
value transactions so if you want to
subscribe to my channel you can give me
ten dollars a month or you can give me
nine dollars a month in ian coin
but why why would they have to give you
ten percent so they get ten percent off
listen this is what yeah this is what
how ever pedia solves the problem so i
don't want to be
come down too hard on them but they have
told me that
if if eos starts
if like the block producers the chinese
block producers of
eos start censoring the content
of everpedia then they'll just
make it possible to to um
transact edits essentially um
using a different coin and that that
would be cool
if we can trust them i just don't like
having to trust people
when when the whole system is supposed
to not require trust
that's the whole idea supposed to be
trustless
i suppose we can just talk about the
positives in a society
with your digital identity owned by
massive corporations crime will be gone
people will get arrested immediately
there'll be no more need for
investigations
passion murder will happen robberies
will happen but people will be
immediately apprehended and
locked up in a private prison for uh you
know for profit
uh-huh sounds right here no more trials
all hard evidence everything's in the
blockchain interact
and we will all live walking with forced
smiles
i don't like that everything is great
i'm happy are you happy ian you're happy
i want to talk about encyclosphere
hey sure okay no that that didn't make
me happy though
that was funny what's um how far along
are you within cyclosphere right now
um so well we've been
doing laying the groundwork basically um
a few different things so we've we've
raised some money
we've incorporated and we've applied
for 501c3 status we've got
uh three different software projects
going
one is called fact seek factseq.org
it's just an encyclopedia meta search
engine
it's it's not much but it's useful for
sure another
one another encyclopedia meta search
engine is
um and these aren't owned by us they're
just affiliated with us
and the the people who are working on
those are people who
are are committed to helping to develop
the standards for for publishing
encyclopedias
um let's see uh the other one is called
encyclosearch.org
um and then uh we are also
directly paying for the development um
it's not encyclopedia related but it's
still decentralized
i have a plug-in for wordpress
that um basically
uh it allows you to run your own
micro blog so like your own twitter feed
that you own
nobody can shut it down via a wordpress
blog
so i'm already doing that on on
a website called startthis.org
but pretty soon that's going to be
running a different theme
and pretty soon after that there's going
to be a plug-in in addition to the theme
and in a later iteration it's actually
going to be possible
for different blogs to talk to each
other and it'll
look just it'll look and act something
like wikipedia does but it's all going
to be transacted
via um blogging uh standards the rss and
adam
standard so like when i pull up one of
your articles i'll be looking at like
the dog went to the zoo
and i'll be able to click on zoo and
it'll take me or like
mouse over the word zoo and it'll like
pull up like uh
um well no uh i was just now talking
about
about um decentralizing social media
using this wordpress plugin
if you're if you're asking about the
encyclosphere
the encyclosphere is um
so it's it's hard to explain and i
apologize a lot of people aren't going
to be able to get it
on on the first pass and it's because
it's it's com
complicated i'm not accusing anyone of
being dense there's all kinds of
brilliant people who need this to
explain several times
and that's not because i'm smart is
because it's got a lot of moving
parts right so the idea is we're
building a
network of encyclopedias or another way
to put it is
we're building a way to network together
all of the existing
encyclopedias and then for just ordinary
people
to add new content very easily and
quickly
so imagine a search engine
that that covers all of the existing
encyclopedias
maybe it doesn't have all of the content
of the articles but at least it has the
metadata so it allows you to
find really quickly and easily the best
encyclopedia articles on each topic
that it might be something you would use
to find articles instead of
wikipedia if it were really good enough
okay what if
in addition to that you had the ability
through say another wordpress blog
plugin
to like just press a button after you've
written your own
one-off encyclopedia article and it's
added
to the same database then you wouldn't
have to ask permission
of anyone to uh to add to this and i
think there would be
all kinds of hobbyists and and um
and experts and professors and
researchers and
all all kinds of people who would be
delighted to
have a an effective way of adding to
the world's knowledge and it wouldn't
just like
be buried way down in the search results
of google
it would actually be in a format that
can be
collected and redistributed in a zillion
different ways
by a bunch of different independent apps
see so it's creating the technical
infrastructure
for people making lots of different
competing apps that tap into the
same body of encyclopedia articles
i would love for like um as i'm reading
any
boing boing article or whatever that i
can mouse over and click on
any word in the article or just mouse
over and it'll show me an overlay if i
want to pop this
you know in cyclosphere app or whatever
it is up browser extension
something like an extension sure as well
as watching a video and you see the
the closed captions i can choose any
word that comes up in the closed caption
and if i see a bird
flying by in the video i could somehow
search what like what is that
so that they have bypass languages they
have that already yeah
for some time actually um i think google
built it where
you could be watching a video and then
stop or or they demoed this
and the ai can identify in an image what
a like google does this you can show an
image and it'll be like this is a lamp
this is an
apple and so that was one of the ideas
you're watching a show
it could pause and you could be like
what's that shirt it would do an instant
google image search and then
show you the product where to buy it
different idea
one's an encyclopedia one's a market
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you